[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chinese monster movie
called million dollar crocodile spoilers
ahead watch out ends take care
ten-year-old xiaoshing likes to wander
around in an abandoned zoo every day
after school he is best friends with a
36 foot long female crocodile named ameo
for the past few months the zoo has been
in shambles because of the lack of funds
hence xiaoxing frequently feeds ameo
through the cells one afternoon he is
hanging by the crocodile pool when his
test paper is blown into the cell
shaoxing carefully goes in to retrieve
it and notices a mayo inside a cave he
holds out a piece of sausage to the
animal but is interrupted when the zoo
owner liu arrives he immediately brings
the kid out and scolds him for putting
his life in danger while he is at it a
group of rowdy restaurant workers
arrives at the zoo since leo can no
longer take care of the crocodiles he
has agreed to sell them to a local
restaurant liu loves his animals dearly
but the situation doesn't allow him to
hold on to them any longer the buyers
easily capture the small ones but a male
gives them a hard time by refusing to
come out of her cave the animal only
trusts liu so he uses a stick to call
her outside she is immediately sedated
and taken away in a vehicle then we are
introduced to a young woman named yon
she has recently returned from a foreign
country after earning a lot of money in
fact she has a bag made of crocodile
leather that is filled with one million
dollars on the way to the city with her
boyfriend jan gets into an argument with
him as a result he strands her in the
middle of the highway meanwhile the
buyers bring the crocodiles to a local
restaurant owned by a gangster named
zhao he plans to slaughter the animals
to sell their meat to foreigners at an
outrageous price the expert cook takes
the responsibility to slaughter the
crocs he doesn't have problems killing
the smaller ones who are still
unconscious because of the tranquilizer
but when he gets to a mayo she suddenly
wakes up and attacks the ropes she is
tied to are not strong enough to
restrain her she breaks them in seconds
and leaps towards the people who were
trying to kill her while struggling she
accidentally breaks a roof with her tail
which causes the cook to end up inside
the pool where the other crocodiles are
kept they violently get on top of him
eventually devouring his body while the
workers are distracted a male breaks out
of a gate and escapes zhao panics and
blames his employees for being careless
he orders them to keep the escape a
secret since they do not want to be
convicted for malpractice at xiaoxing's
home his father beiji who is a policeman
is mad at him for losing his test papers
xiao xing tells him what happened to it
but beiji thinks the kid is just making
up a story to hide that he didn't get
good results a while later he leaves for
work asking xiao xing to stay home
because he is grounded meanwhile yan has
been walking on the highway for an hour
cursing her boyfriend she holds her bag
close relieved that she at least has the
money she decides to walk through a tea
farm which is a shorter way to the bus
station however she soon regrets her
decision as a 36 foot long giant
crocodile blocks her way she freaks out
and climbs on a pole to save her life
when the animal doesn't move she hits it
with the bag to try to send it away but
she yet again regrets her decision when
a mayo eats the bag as a whole it walks
away right after leaving jan in shock
she realizes that the bag is worth more
than her life and runs around looking
for the animal after not finding it she
asks a couple for the way to the police
station in xiaoxing's home he is passing
time instead of studying his friends
call him outside for a trip to a nearby
lake a mischievous xiaoshing assumes he
can return home before his father and
joins them at the police station ian
tells beiji about her bag that had her
phone and a million dollars which are
now inside a massive crocodile's stomach
the story is so absurd that he thinks
she is trying to prank him but when yon
repeatedly insists that she is telling
the truth beiji asks her to prove the
existence of a giant crocodile she takes
him to the tea farm and reenacts what
happened they also meet the couple from
earlier who claim they haven't seen any
animals around the area yan still
insists that she is telling the truth
which only makes the others think she's
suffering from a mental disorder that is
making her delusional beijing is now
sure that she is trying to mess with him
he walks away but yan doesn't stop
following him she inquires if there are
places in the town that hold crocodiles
which reminds beiji of the zoo seeing
that she is desperate he decides to give
her a last chance and takes her to the
zoo but it has already been closed
permanently beijing calls liu to find
out that the restaurant owner zhao owns
all the crocodiles after that beijing
calls zhao who makes his minion lie that
all the crocodiles are confined to beiji
this confirms that jan has been bluffing
he asks her to go back to her city and
drives away
in the lake xiao xing and his friends
are having the time of their lives
unaware that a mayo is swimming in the
same waters a renowned alcoholic sees
the animal and warns the kids about it
but they think he is joking a distraught
ian is walking down the street when
beiji approaches her again he makes her
call her phone and the call still goes
through this further proves that the
crocodile didn't eat her phone beijing
stops a bus and urges her to go back to
her city yen retaliates and cries about
her million dollars making him
forcefully get her inside the bus and
send her away still yen is not someone
who gives up that easily she jumps out
of the window of the moving bus and
follows beijing again a man comes to him
complaining about his missing goat beige
goes to the lake where it was last seen
to investigate yen notices blood
spreading on the surface of the water
when beijing jumps inside he finds the
goat's decapitated head this makes him
realize that ian might have been telling
the truth his home is also near the pond
which means there is a possibility the
crocodile might attack his son he
immediately rushes home to see a naked
xiaoshing playing outside he hugs his
son tightly grateful that he is safe yan
also arrives having followed beiji she
stays at their home with xiaoshing so
beiji can go out and investigate the
case further when it gets dark xiaoshan
cooks noodles for both of them unaware
that a mayo is right outside the house
meanwhile beijing makes a stop at zhao's
restaurant and the broken gates make it
clear that they are the reason the
crocodile escaped he teaches them a
lesson for lying and urges them to file
an official complaint about the missing
animal after that he calls the zookeeper
liu and tells him everything since a
mayo is a female crocodile leo thinks
she must be somewhere near the waters
where she can lay eggs beigey registers
his home is in the middle of the only
two water bodies in the town he
hurriedly rushes home to make sure his
son is safe in the meantime ameyo enters
the house and is climbing up the stairs
when xiao xing sees her he recognizes
her as his friend but yann panics she
tries to protect herself with a knife
but it only triggers the otherwise calm
crocodile she attacks them and wreaks
havoc in the house shaoxing and diane
hide inside a locked room but a male
breaks in through the wall as a last
resort they climb up the roof through
the window xiaoxing is safely up but yan
has trouble following him she is seconds
away from being attacked by the
crocodile when beijing arrives and hits
it with his bike a male falls to the
ground and runs away leaving the house
in a mess by now the entire town has
been warned about the dangerous animal
walking among them soldiers are
appointed to capture her and the matter
turns into national news in the
following scene everyone is in the
police station when zhao is alone yan
asks him how fast a crocodile can digest
the food it eats zhao knows nothing
about the animal's anatomy but still he
confidently claims that they can digest
anything within hours of eating it as
they talk he finds out a mayo has a
million dollars inside her stomach
driven by greed he makes it his mission
to get the bag before anyone else finds
the crocodile he and his minions drive
towards the lake to hunt it but are
stopped by police on the way they are
blocking the road to ensure the animal
does no harm hence in turn the group
takes a shorter way to the lake that
runs through the woods in the police
station yan hugs beiji from behind
begging him to catch the crocodile soon
however beijiy realizes she is doing it
to steal his gun he warns her to never
try anything like that again if she
doesn't want to spend the night in jail
the next morning the military and the
police get ready to go on a search
mission leo also joins beiji since he is
the only person who can control the
animal yan is eager to go on a search to
ensure she will be the first one to get
her hands on her money however since she
doesn't know the way to the mountains
she tricks xiao xing into helping her
while in the woods they bump into zhao
and his minions and follow them the
group eventually finds a footprint near
a lake they need bait to bring the
animal out so zhao uses yan and
xiaoshing as bait they are hung upside
down by the lake ameo sees them and
recognizes xiao xing as the kind kid who
always fed her hence she doesn't attack
the two one of zhao's minions tries to
hit her with a dart which triggers her
yet again she runs back into the water
and drags jiao behind because he is
stuck in a fishing net beiji and liu
arrive at the scene and see that xiao
has somehow survived without any injury
right then ameo jumps on him and devours
his body xiao xing yan and liu follow
the crocodile trying to control her ian
fires a shot at her which makes her
violent she smacks the car and runs away
to the field they lose her on the tea
farm but we see her re-entering the lake
from the other side of the road the
police start clearing the area and
alerting people about the animal yan
suggests the police use her phone's gps
system to track email the police work on
getting the data and eventually find out
the location beijing liu set off to look
for her since only liu can control her
they see her in the shallow part of the
lake and bring her to the bank in no
time liu is doing a great job keeping
her calm that is until one of zhao's
minions attacks ameo for killing his
boss she loses her temper again and
starts attacking everyone inside liu
tries his best to calm her down but she
in turn attacks him as well as a last
resort beijing shoots her in the head
which ends her life at last we see a
mayo looking at liu's dead body with
teary eyes she never wanted to kill
anyone let alone her keeper but she did
what she had to do to keep herself safe
in the last scene we see yan counting
the bills she got from amejo's body they
are mostly destroyed but she doesn't
want to give up on them somewhere else
by the lake ameyo's eggs hatch giving
birth to her offspring subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching